that wasn't super easy what was your
favorite costume from Black Panther
wakanda forever and why was it that
costume designer Ruth Carter had to make
three times as many pieces for this
movie Let's dive in we save a lot of
fabric in that custom number one it's
time for a new super suit costume
designer Ruth Carter told Vanity Fair
that she knew redesigning the Black
Panther suit would be a challenge that
process was new to me but it was one
that director Ryan coogler encouraged
her to take on saying whenever I see a
Batman film the suit is different the
suit is new it's still Batman but
there's this fresh new thing that's
being presented that's what he wanted me
to bring to the Black Panther film
Carter put plenty of thought into Black
Panther's new look and took inspiration
from the fact that she saw this as a
woman's story this fabulous new suit
comes with silver and gold
embellishments that turn it into in
Carter's words a panther suit Fit For A
Princess I saw so many beautiful ways
that we could represent it on this
costume number two a true warrior
dresses the part black panther wakanda
forever gives us more of a glimpse into
okoye's fashion sense when she visits
jury at MIT and this look definitely
makes a statement wearing a pair of
Louis Vuitton sunglasses along with a
bold red bodysuit with a uniquely
wakandan design along the front this
look is far from just eye candy okoya's
red bodysuit is courtesy of Adidas and
it was made using body banding that
athletes like because it supports their
knees and muscles this means akoye is
still able to do everything a general of
the Dora melange would need to oh while
looking great I like it number three how
many costumes do you think were in this
movie Ruth Carter guessed she'd made 700
pieces for black panther but this time
around she made three times as many with
an estimated 2100 she explained this by
I pointing out that she had not only all
of wakanda to style but the newly
introduced Kingdom of talukan and the
wakanda Navy in this movie as well and
with so many great pieces to choose from
which one is Carter's favorite well
apparently all of them I would go up to
each one like privately and say this is
my favorite costume number four would
you wear 3D printed clothes we are
creating costumes with 3D printing Five
3D printers were used in the making of
this movie's wardrobe and Ruth Carter
has praised the process by saying that
you can make lightweight pieces much
easier by it Carter got the idea for
shuri's White Funeral Hood upon seeing
3D printed hoods being modeled at a
fashion show in Rome telling Vanity Fair
I just had to have that even Leticia
writes elephant tusk earrings were 3D
printed so that they represented what
would be Ivory even though they're not
Ivory rather Carter wanted these
earrings to be more of an homage to the
continent number five live dressing for
the water was the hardest part Ruth
Carter admitted that she struggled
finding just the right fabric that would
float without causing major wardrobe
malfunctions you want it to look like
ballet but it usually just goes up
straight weights and tethers were added
to fix the problem but Carter still had
a challenge ahead the costumes for black
panther had mostly been made using
leather and other Fabrics that would get
destroyed in the water and so for the
sequel Carter needed to recreate
everything from scratch using silicone I
love that costume with the cape and
everything number six be prepared this
scene might make you cry black panther
wakanda forever opens up on t'challa's
funeral where we see a wakandan United
entirely in white Ruth Carter told W
magazine we spoke with historians in
West Africa specifically and they told
us that in Africa the color for funerals
is usually white or red Carter felt that
red already had enough of a presence in
the first movie and so she opted for all
white a film takes a deep dive into the
wonderful world that they created number
seven Namor could have looked entirely
different if tenochuerta had his way he
would have been wearing a full suit I
asked for for a whole suit you know with
muscles in fact he wasn't happy when he
found out how revealing his costume was
I call them the shame short but
fortunately for Huerta the shame shorts
weren't the only part to his outfit for
the leader of the talocan Ruth Carter
Drew through heavy Mayan influence
especially on namor's neck piece
inspired by a pyramid in Mexico
dedicated to The Feathered Serpent his
Jade earring and conch shells represent
water meanwhile multiple versions of his
feathered headdress needed to be made
some silicone-based for use in water and
some for use outside of it they did it
so well number eight the future is now
Ruth Carter worked with Adidas and the
school for experimental education and
design to update Sheree's wardrobe for
the sequel her hollowed out sneakers
come courtesy of Adidas and as awesome
as these are they're nothing compared to
Sherry's Adidas tracksuit this number
comes complete with an extra piece of
fabric in the back that Billows out like
a cape when shury's on her motorcycle
director Ryan coogler warned Carter that
he didn't want to focus as much on the
clothing for this movie and that the
Wardrobe should reflect the somber mood
of the film and so for the tracksuits
color we wanted it to be the Royal Color
Purple number nine how well do you know
you your Mayan history when shuri is
taken by the talokan the ceremonial
dress she's given to wear draws heavy
influence from Mayan history and of all
things Pottery as Ruth Carter explained
to the times the Mayans used a lot of
sheer fabric so the dress is sheer to
reflect that culture the Mayans were
also the inventors of rubber meaning
that Carter had an easy list of
materials to turn to in making this
dress the neck piece is made using clay
beads and Carter has said that she Drew
plenty of inspiration from my invases
the depicted rulers and people of
nobility number 10. you can't help but
notice this queen While most world
leaders would probably go to a meeting
of the United Nations in a boring old
suit she shows up wearing an elegant
purple gown to represent how in Carter's
words because of t'challa's death she is
now both the queen and the king the
crown Angela Bassett wears in this scene
was styled based on isisolo which is a
Zulu married woman's hat the crown was
also 3 3D printed to also represented
new Innovations number 11. this is a
bold new look for her Nakia mostly wore
green throughout the first movie to
represent her as a member of the River
tribe but Ruth Carter wanted to shake
things up a bit in the sequel here she's
introduced wearing a salmon dress which
Lupita Nyong'o has described by saying
this look was hard to finalize
apparently the dress needed to be both
flattering and practical while the color
needed to stand strong against the
natural Greens in the background number
12 we had to see her in green eventually
Nakia returns to her trademark color for
her submersible suit which Ruth Carter
has said was inspired by South African
body painters and Lupita Nyong'o has
praised the costume for its celebration
of African culture I'm
deeply proud harder reveal that the suit
was first designed entirely in white
before being painted with tribal lines
and scanned into the computer
bioluminescent paint was added to the
front just so the suit can shine a
little more underwater number 13 there
was a lot to consider during filming the
Jabari are supposed to wear wood armor
but Ruth Carter didn't want to address
the actors in something so hard and
heavy considering they were going to be
doing stunt work so instead the breast
plate up embaku's armor was sculpted
from clay before being cast and painted
to resemble wood from there Carter faced
a second problem making the costume
heavy enough so that it wouldn't float
in water to add to it Carter decided to
think Roman gladiator adding a raffia
skirt and sandals so that Winston Duke
could actually perform underwater it's
clear that the costume department for
black panther put plenty of thought into
creating costumes that felt both
authentic and futuristic which look blew
you away the most make sure to let us
know down down in the comments